Hayao Miyazaki was born in Tokyo on January 5, 1941.
As a boy, he liked to read and draw cartoons.
After graduating from university in 1963, Miyazaki joined the Toei Animation Company.
At Toei, he worked on many animated movies like the famous "Puss in Boots".
In 1984, he made "Nausicaa of the Valley of the Wind",...
...which was based on a comic book he wrote.
Because this movie was so successful,...
...Miyazaki was able to start his own animation company, Studio Ghibli.
One of Miyazaki's most loved movies is "My Neighbor Totoro", made in 1987.
It is a children's movie, but many adults like it too.
The movie is about two sisters...
...who become friends with an enormous, supernatural animal named Totoro.
It is a very warmhearted story...
...with many fantastic characters such as Cat Bus, a cat that is also a bus.
Miyazaki's 2001 movie, "Spirited Away", was even more popular than "Totoro".
In fact, it made more money than any other movie in Japanese history.
All of Miyazaki's movies contain strange but charming people and creatures.
Many of his stories happen in worlds that are different from ours.
However, they still show his ideas about real life.
He often points out how humans hurt the natural world.
He thinks people should change how they live.
Miyazaki's movies combine fantasy and reality in an original way.
This may be why so many people like his movies.